er träumte schon von der Rente auf
Mallorca suchte einen würdigen
Nachfolger als Küchenchef doch jetzt ist
Sternekoch Heinz Winkler Tod völlig
unerwartet im Alter von 73 Jahren sein
Tod wirft Fragen auf
was geschah in den letzten Stunden
Rückblick Aschau 27 Oktober Heinz
Winkler ist wie üblich in seiner
fünf-sterne-residenz Koch dort für die
Gäste unerwartet taucht Koch Sandro B
auf obwohl er nicht zum Dienst
eingeteilt war gegen 18 Uhr 30 öffnen
Sie die erste Flasche Wein laut
Angestellten hat Winkler an diesem Abend
viel Redebedarf die Scheidung von seiner
Frau Daniela steht im Raum das Ehepaar
habe sich in dieser Woche heftig
gestritten ums Geld gegen 21 Uhr ist
Winkler stark angetrunken Sandro bietet
ihm anni nach Hause zu fahren was dann
geschieht weiß nur Sandro B klar ist der
Tod von Sternekoch Heinz Winkler er
wirft viele Fragen